so where were we going now we are going
to our cabin this place is we fell in
love with it when we started working
here it's like this little hidden spot
in the city
electronic dance music has always been
fertile ground for the blending of
musical genres Canadian DJs fool men and
bear witness collectively known as A
Tribe Called red combined the sounds of
traditional native palo of drum circles
with electronic dance music to create
something we call electric power I was
able to sit in with the Tribe Called red
as they started to work on a new batch
of music so it's a little bit of a tight
squeeze getting in here at a heart to
find studio on a residential street in
Toronto so how did Tribe Called red
start it all grew out of a club night
yeah so back in like 2008 a few of us
got together in Ottawa we didn't really
know each other all that well but just
came together under the idea that we
were all native DJs working in the city
and let's throw a party together the
reaction that we got from our community
was that you've started something you've
created this space for us and you have
to keep doing it now did you feel
pressure
um not so much prep well I mean it was
there was a really quick realization
that we were doing something much bigger
than we thought we were we thought we
were just throwing a party and would
advertise to our community but really
quickly we realized that it meant a lot
more than that than that you know that
taking up space within the urban
environment as indigenous people is is a
difficult thing sometimes to actually
have a community and a culture that is
urban and is indigenous is it new we've
been here since you know these were
forts and villages but our visibility
has changed well I mean I've always said
that we're part of a wave you know like
like we threw this party and got told we
had to keep doing it by the
the community so it's we're always
following that way not really eating it
[Music]
when you're creating new projects do you
keep in mind this cultural landscape
this wave that you're talking about I
mean I guess it's finding a balance
between those things you know break it
down into DJ terms are reading the room
our second album was called nation to
nation because we were producing it at a
time when there was a new movement
happening in Canada called I don't know
more the First Nations protest movement
is quietly spreading across the country
First Nations protestors gathered on
Parliament Hill once again and
indigenous people in Canada all together
stood up and said we're not going to
quietly let things happen anymore
there was this huge influx of indigenous
people in Ottawa who came from all over
the country to protest you know so that
album nation-to-nation even got its name
nation to nation because that's what
we're calling for we're calling to have
a conversation a talk with Canada from
the indigenous nation to the sublimation
so you know that vibe everything that
was happening got put into the album the
energy of a protest movement is only one
ingredient in their music a tribe called
read uses samples of native drum circles
as the basis for almost all of their
music what started off as an experiment
sampling drum sounds from Pow Wow videos
they found on YouTube has turned into a
collaboration so I was gonna bring this
up really quick I asked him to give me
different patterns so they gave us
different patterns that they sing with
so this is a sidestep groove so the
sides of it
and then there's like straight the very
first thing that we ever did with power
music was just doing a live mashup and
it's because we had a grass dance song
that was open at the beginning so you
just had straight singing you could just
loop that and then through a dubstep
instrumental underneath it you know it's
like it's like finding any other sample
like finding a break beat that was like
a clean break that was that was super
funky that you could sample you know
that was isolated and it's slowly grown
into us having this relationship with
the drum groups now where they give us
what we need so we're sitting off the
side of the drum so those drums that you
heard one of those is in almost every
song we made so what is a drum circle la
went to Prior Lake Minnesota to find out
I met up with iron boy an intertribal
drum circle based in Minneapolis
although they haven't collaborated with
the Tribe Called red they've been
performing at powwows all over the
United States including what's
considered the largest powwow in the
world The Gathering of Nations in New
Mexico where they were crowned champions
in the northern drum contest in 2015
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm breathing fast like a typical
northern drum circle song has a
call-and-response structure divided into
push-ups or verses the first lead will
sing a line then the group will respond
with the chorus once the chorus is sung
and repeated the next singer in the
circle takes the lead to start the
second push up although the sound might
feel traditional the members of iron boy
write their own music like this song
composed by member Charles Larrabee the
most part I try to visualize the dancers
dancing and just talk about their
movements like she knocks jae-ha
specifies hopped on bow the women's long
braids when they spin they see them
flying when there's something noon I
feel like it's worthy then I'll send it
to NFA if it clicks in a statement this
is very similar to a jazz band sitting
in the car generally driving and come
back in the Lincoln Park
basically when we have a song and kind
of happy facing rules but you try to
upend the rules so just kind of like
contemporary music we use usually use a
lot of words
well school is usually straight songs
how many words just because of there was
a time until up to 1970 78 everything
was out loud so really you kind of see
this movement now a lot of people are
moving back towards some of those like
ways like using move words and their
song and stuff like that and a lot of
language and I'm taking pride in that
language in 1978 not that long ago the
US government passed the American Indian
Religious Freedom Act which came to
protect the rights of Native Americans
to practice their culture something that
we value you know our culture we value
it so much that you know we're gonna
carry this on until we make our journey
and we're gonna teach as many young
people as we can along the way it's a
huge responsibility
you know this drum here is and this
represents a grandfather spirit the drum
takes care of us to take care
[Music]
[Music]
you know instead of using like air horns
or sirens were a lot like a lot of
electronic music well we use the calls
power Falls which it has the same thing
that has the same effect and you know
you're playing to an indigenous audience
like those those have the same
effectively people react to it the same
way it's no crazy I get I get people who
hit me up all the time they're like hey
man do you think you can give me that
that that sound you guys use cuz I'd
really like to play it I'm like a like a
lacrosse game or something like that
like that so it's like they want to use
that as a goal horn they don't you know
it's so weird but like that's where
we're at right now replacing the air
horns and that that's just a way of then
digitizing the space that we're in yeah
well we would add like a ton of other
instruments anything we get our hands on
really
they're like this faster slower
to admit a decision early on that they
wanted all the risers to be self-made so
it's a lot of stuff that we messed
around with in Calgary we were in a
National Music Center in Calgary and
they have like just a bunch of sense a
consent museum but they allow people to
have residency's there they'll have
access to every basically - almost every
single synth known even with the
legendary Tonto
this is Tonto or the original new tambul
Orchestra it was created by Malcolm
Cecil in the early 1970s the room-sized
multi Tamriel polyphonic analog
synthesizer
was used by many artists including the
Isley Brothers and Stevie Wonder only
one was ever made and it now lives in
Canada at the National Music Center in
Calgary Alberta I could bring up the OG
actually I asked two men to break down
some of the elements used in a track
they were working on so I'm just playing
the throne
[Music]
[Applause]
and just added some drums to that
[Laughter]
[Music]
one more element for the track was found
when member of Canadian Parliament Romeo
saw ganache delivered a passionate
speech on behalf of indigenous rights to
the House of Commons watching indigenous
Twitter and Instagram and Facebook
explode as soon as that happened I was
like okay this is definitely a moment
and I mean we felt that moment ourselves
become part of it yeah you want you want
to do something with it because again
like when we first started making this
music it was to make something that
everybody could enjoy and everyone could
appreciate but that would be instantly
recognizable and identifiable to
indigenous people so to take a moment
for indigenous people and then weave it
into a song you know that's that's
telling our fans that this is this is
for you has there ever been resistance
from an older generation that didn't
understand the the combination of
electronic music with Pow Wow
but it's different to them yeah I mean
it there's nobody who's ever really
there post that we shouldn't be doing
what we're doing but people who don't
necessarily connect with it
I have always said that they see the
relevance of what we're doing because
it's connecting with youth you know so
many of us didn't grow up having you
know people that represented us in the
media you know we all kind of go back to
the few little things that were there
you know seeing Buffy sainte-marie on
Sesame Street is a huge one you know and
and I think one of the things that we
have an opportunity to do is start to
you know to give that to a younger
generation that that we are out here
being indigenous in our on our own terms
you know not not being not having to be
boxed into something that isn't us
we did a video for our song suplex
about our native wrestler kind of making
it on his own terms next thing we knew
after that video came out all these
parents were sending in these different
photos of their kids who had had made
their own luchador mask got them to cut
the sleeves off of their jean jackets to
look like the wrestler in the video yeah
it's so kind of with us dreaming about
what it would have been like to have an
indigenous representation that was true
to who we were growing up we had given
it to a younger generation just through
our imagining it and a lot of ways that
we make a lot of music that we have to
have at the purpose room it has to
service our community in some shape or
form or else it doesn't make sense to do
it for us that's what drives us to even
create and to perform is just
does it make sense for our community
that's the thing that's our moral
compass that we follow